[Music]
i hate to end on such a dour note but uh
something terrible
has happened tragedy has struck
and i don't know how else to put this
so i'm just going to come out and say it
full frontal has been canceled
now i know what you're thinking
what's full frontal
well it's the late night comedy show
hosted by samantha b
and i know what you're thinking who is
samantha bee
well maybe stop asking questions for a
minute and just listen cnn has the
heartbreaking story it says after seven
seasons full frontal with samantha b
will not be returning to tbs this fall
the show announced monday on its
official twitter account uh the talk
show has been on the air since february
2016 on tbs home to a host of syndicated
shows including the big bang theory and
friends
uh they said quote to our loyal fans we
love you you're very special go home and
go home in peace the show's statement
continued during its run full frontal
santa samantha was nominated four times
in the best variety talk series emmy
category one of the show's specials full
frontal with samantha b presents not the
white house correspondents dinner earned
an emmy for outstanding writing for a
variety special in 2017.
asked about the reason for the
cancellation a tbs spokesperson told cnn
quote as we continue to shape our new
programming strategy we've made some
difficult business-based decisions
i'm sorry but i just don't buy it
business-based decision
sounds like code for sexism to me
i mean i can't imagine why else they
would cancel the show especially since
it's been on such a roll recently i mean
just to show you what i mean let's play
a short clip of the abrorious comedic
monologue she delivered about the roe
decision a couple of weeks ago just get
ready for some gut-busting comedy folks
listen
medical professionals say that these
prosecutions are often based on faulty
science and disproportionately hurt
low-income women and women of color
which at this point is basically the
slogan for our country and if you think
republicans will stop at abortion itself
well
bless your heart some red state
legislators in places like idaho are
even prepared to outlaw some of the most
popular forms of birth control you heard
that right outlaw birth control what's
next outlaw condoms
oh wait that's actually a great name for
a condom company when republicans
propose bills that suggest life begins
at fertilization they're making the
argument that just having an iud could
be a form of murder it is not it is a
form of making sure the boyfriend you
had in your early twenties doesn't stay
in your life forever i'll be honest i
feel hopeless i feel rage that every
woman in america has been left to make a
plan for how to take care of themselves
in a country that values a zygote more
than them i feel like my throat hurts
it's probably just the coveted
now was any of that remotely funny
no
was it uncomfortable and embarrassing to
watch
yes
is samantha be kind of like the socially
unaware dinner guest who keeps launching
into long stories that are supposed to
be funny or interesting but instead are
just boring and the more she talks the
more awkward it gets as everyone else at
the table shoots glances at each other
each praying silently that she'll stop
talking so they can get the conversation
back on track
yes 100
but is that a good excuse to cancel the
only female light night comedy host
absolutely not
truly there's no telling why exactly
this decision has been made after seven
seasons
some have speculated that they're
canceling the show because it's terrible
and has no audience some have pointed
out that its ratings were so low that
even the wnba felt sorry for it some in
fact have actually speculated that
samantha b was bankrolled by the wnba
because it made the league's ratings
look better by comparison i don't know
if that's true or not there are some
who've said that uh samantha b's brand
as this scowling humorless wine mom of
late night just didn't resonate with
viewers
some have said that if they wanted to be
yelled at by an ill-tempered middle-aged
blonde woman they just go work the cash
register at a grocery store
some have pointed to the fact that her
show made less money than a child's
overpriced lemonade stand some have said
that tbs could replace its full frontal
revenue just by holding like a yard sale
once a month
some have even claimed that comedy shows
are supposed to be funny
but they say samantha b show is about as
funny as watching someone drown
they've said that there have been
house fires funnier than samantha bee
there are some who said that that that
the black plague was a hilarious
slapstick farce compared to full front
of what's the man to be some have said
many other things like this and i find
them all offensive
i do not endorse any of those statements
i am simply telling you what other
people have said probably
as for myself i can tell you
that i had faith
a deep abiding faith
that samantha b would at some point
during some episode managed to tell a
funny joke
she tried for seven seasons and failed
but you know what stand-up comedians
always say this is their motto they say
if at first you bomb get back up there
and bomb again and keep bombing over and
over and over again forever
that's either stand-up comedians or
al-qaeda i'm not sure which one but if
you keep going
and keep telling jokes however bad they
might be statistically it just seems
almost certain that eventually you'll
stumble upon a funny one right
samantha b never got there
because tbs canceled her before she had
a chance
they only gave her six years
which is not nearly long enough nbc has
given seth meyers more time than that to
figure it out and he's still trying
which means that this is sexism once
again rearing its ugly head and telling
a woman that she isn't funny
which of course is true
it usually is but she could have been
funny
one day
i believed in her
i was watching and rooting for her
well i wasn't watching nobody was but i
was rooting
so i washed my hands of this travesty i
had nothing to do with it this isn't my
fault
it isn't samantha bee's fault you know
it's your fault
and tbs is full for not supporting her
and believing in her
and because of your callous disregard
samantha b
hit the glass ceiling and rather than
breaking through it she splattered
against it like a bug on a windshield
for that reason you are all canceled
shame on you all how dare you
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there